[Musique]
comme je t'aimais comme on s'aimait
j'étais alors encore
enfant et dans la vie gment j'allais le
cœur joyeux comme le
printemps les fleurs des champs et les
pré vers dont le parfum nous
enivrait é pouri moi tout l'univers
comme je t'aimais comme on
s'aimait les beaux dimanches de
Frat quand on allait à
robasson danser sous les lauriers
tremblant tout s'allonger sur le
gazon comme des oiseaux dans les
buissons on s'embrassait à chaque
instant quand on allait à Robin son les
beau dimanches de
printemps comme je t'aimais comme on
s'aimait mais ce beau temps n'a pas
duré sans un biser tu m'as quitté comme
un oiseau s'en é
allé depuis je vis du souvenir des soirs
d'été où l'on
faisait des rêves fous pour
l'avenir comme je t'aimais comme on
s'aimait les beaux dimanches de
printemps quand on allait à
robinon comme il est loin ce joli temps
où je chantais comme un
Pinon j'ignorais tout la
trahison la jalousie ta voix qui
m quand on allit à Robinson les beau
dimanches
d'
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Pr